aussi incontournable que le sapin à la
bûche de noël et quand on évoque la
bûche on pense aux 22 dessert le
sauternes est un classique mais les vins
moelleux un peu moins sucré commence
aussi à trouver leur place sur nos
tables de fêtes du brésil en afrique
bonnet ont pu assister à une des
dernières vendanges de l'année c'était
la semaine passée sur les pentes du
coteau du layon en on joue jamais
l'expression à perte de vue n'aura été à
ce point justifié 20 hectares de vignes
dans le brouillard pour une vendange
particulièrement tardive mais le fruit
de la récolte mérite bien ça le raisin
offre à cette saison le meilleur de lui
même parce triés sur le bas de la grappe
c'est-à-dire flétri par le soleil et
avec du botrytis un champignon sur la
partie supérieure
c'est ce que l'on appelle la pourriture
noble il y a très très peu de pulpe à
l'intérieur c'est ce qui permet d'avoir
le maximum de sucre a envoyé ça ça fait
comme un filament d'ailleurs moi j'ai
les mains complètement lui entêté plein
de sucre quand on a les mains collante
ça veut dire que déjà c'est en partie
gagné cueillis à la main grappes par
grappes et en plusieurs fois il faut
prendre soin de ce raisin fortement
concentrée en sucre nous sommes sur les
pentes du coteau du layon au château des
noyés dans le val de loire une région
qui commence sérieusement à concurrencer
des liquoreux les plus réputés comme le
sauternes
ici le propriétaire soigne la qualité de
ce cépage le chenin et son prix aussi je
ne suis pas du tout pour avoir des vins
trop cher je crois qu'il faut un
équilibre en tout aussi bien à l
équilibre avec l'acidité le l'alcool et
le sucre aussi un équilibre entre le
rapport qualité prix pour une bouteille
de 50 centilitres comme celle ci il faut
compter 12 euros une cuvée vieilles
vignes qui a nécessité huit riz
successifs
nous voici dans les caves du restaurant
parisien de philippe faur-brac élus en
92 meilleur sommelier du monde pour lui
la référence des vins sucrés reste le
sauternes bien à l'abri ils protègent ce
magnum de château yquem 66 vendu à la
carte 1400 euros
mais sa curiosité le pousse
naturellement vers ces autres vins aux
qualités souvent comparables comme le
vin de paille dans le jura le loupiac ou
le barça dans le sud-ouest le toqué ou
le gewurtztraminer en alsace le mont
louis où le coteaux de l'aubance dans la
vallée de la loire première dégustation
avec le coteau du layon sont des vins
qui ont l'énergie une séduction
extraordinaire parce qu'il ya de
l'onctuosité et en même temps il ya
cette fibre minérale légèrement acidulé
qui permet d'avoir un côté très
rafraîchissant deuxième essai avec le
loupiac embauche à la caresse des grands
moelleux avec en même temps une énergie
également une un dynamisme qui est assez
intéressant c'est des ventes plus
somptueux au total il existe une
trentaine de vins liquoreux différents
en france
ici dans ce scellier en juin du xviie
siècle la fermentation se fait de façon
régulière et tranquille ça c'est dur
toujours à boire avec modération